françois hollande aux mureaux une visite
de terrain à la rencontre de la
population un an après son élection
un million de chômeurs de plus durant le
dernier kaka et le chômage qui
continuent leur course aux priorités qui
vaille c'est l'emploi emploi et jeunesse
au programme de cette matinée ce mardi
au collège jean vilar des mureaux de
jeunes ont signé un contrat de
génération qui les lie chacun un senior
de la même entreprise
l'état s'est engagé à créer 70 mille
contrats de génération en france et
aussi cent mille emplois d'avenir d'ici
fin 2013
comme ce jeune qui commencera le 13 mai
en tant qu'animateur auprès d'une
association de sa ville j'ai eu un bts
dans le field environnement énergétique
travailler avec l'office du
développement durable c'est vraiment je
dirais un complément par rapport à ma
formation à la sensibiliser la
population sur les consommations
d'énergie c'est ce qui me plaît vraiment
pour nous c'était une évidence deux
recruter un emploi de à venir aux
mureaux le développement durable pour
des finitions l'environnement
l'économique et le social
donc c'est tout à fait dans la
continuité de nos actions
avantage non négligeable le financement
public à hauteur de 75% du salaire brut
sur une base au smic
votre but de cette matinée la signature
de la convention objectifs 2013 2015
pour les quartiers populaires ce sera
par exemple un renforcement de la
présence de pôle emploi
et aussi deux mille nouveaux postes
créés non pas pour résorber le chômage
selon les termes de françois hollande
mais pour suivre les millions de
personnes en recherche d'emploi
je crois qu'il ya un travail aussi
affaire avec pôle emploi parce que les
missions locales sont limitées en âge
bien évidemment il ya des efforts à
faire sur des certains endroits mais on
le prend nous avec une approche globale
sur la vivre lors de son discours le
président a aussi annoncé 2000 emplois
francs dès le mois de juin sur 10 sites
pilotes en france où le chômage est le
plus élevé côté initiative la banque
publique d'investissement mettra un
fonds spécifique à disposition des
créateurs d'entreprises dans les
quartiers populaires fait en sorte
qu'ils protestent rhume en tout soit mis
à disposition des entreprises des
français pour
lutter contre le chômage je dois
maintenant les mettre en oeuvre les
convaincre ceux qui peuvent être utile
de le faire et à commencer par les chefs
d'entreprise
et puis dire à toute cette jeunesse qui
attend qu'ils espèrent qu'un sa place
dans notre société
une visite achevée sur une note festive